I used to homeschool my kids and you
know that was a big deal to me I wanted
to be able to have input based on the
values that I saw we're important I
think every parent has that right to be
able to say I want my kids to go to this
school or that's cool
whoa
in Kalispell Montana there's a battle
under way over whether parents have a
right to choose where their kids go to
school kendra Espinosa sends her
daughters Naomi and Sarah to a local
private school my kids go to stillwater
Christian school I'm trying to input
that values based system into them I
want that foundation to be there from an
early age and so the academics of
stillwater Christian school is even more
challenging than the public school and I
think my kids needed that but as a
single mother working two jobs Espinoza
has struggled to meet tuition payments
so she turned to a scholarship program
run by the state of Montana well their
scholarship program is a program that
would allow private taxpayers to
contribute to a scholarship organization
and they would just get a modest tax
credit at the end of the year one
hundred and fifty dollar maximum so they
would just pool that money into an
organization they would then distribute
the scholarship and his people the
parents can use that money that tuition
money for the school of their choice and
that was what the intent was that it
would be the choice of the parents to be
able to use that money for their kids
tuition but Espinoza ran into a problem
the governor and the Department of
Revenue decided that the families
couldn't use the scholarship money if
the parents were sending their kids to a
religious school so late last year the
espinoza's along with two other families
sued the state on constitutional grounds
they're represented by the libertarian
law firm the Institute for justice erica
smith is an attorney working out the
case this rule threatens to totally
crippled the program because like in any
state most of the private schools in
Montana are religious the Department of
Revenue's rule violates both the Montana
and United States Constitution both
constitutions protect the right to
religious liberty and equal protection
and the government is not allowed to
have a benefit program that excludes
religious options the United States
Supreme Court has already said in two
different decisions that these
scholarships school choice programs do
not violate the First Amendment's
Establishment Clause and are completely
constitutional
so this separation of church and state
argument doesn't have any basis in legal
precedent I would do anything for my
kids I didn't have a lot of opportunity
when I was growing up she didn't have it
it just wasn't there and so I want to
give that for my kids